vous le savez christian quesada ce le
candidat du jeu les 12 coups de midi
arrêté pour détention d'imagés
pédopornographiques en mars 2019 a fait
l'objet de deux documentaires sur ces 8
c'est dans le cadre d'un droit de
réponse que le producteur de ce
documentaire a envoyé un courrier en
prison à christian quesada soutenant
plusieurs questions et invitant l'homme
a donné sa version des faits un courrier
auquel a répondu christian quesada il ya
quelques jours
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il semble très en colère selon lui
les différentes enquêtes le concernant
ne sont pas conformes à la réalité des
faits dans son courrier christian
quesada s'en prend aussi aux propos
tenus à son sujet sur notre plateau lors
des différents débats ce soir nous vous
dévoilons tout le contenu de cette
lettre en exclusivité dans des pmp
bonsoir vous êtes le réalisateur du
documentaire on reçoit ce soir le
réalisateur le producteur ou le style le
styliste conseiller visage très belle
peau cyril très belle épiderme tiré un
très bel épiderme l'a souvent dit vous
aussi merci voilà guilo alors dont
christian quesada vous avez écrit ouais
enfin vous directement
ouais en fait on a fait donc deux
documentaires sur christian quesada et
c'est vrai qu'on a rencontré pas mal de
gens de son entourage dont il y avait
évidemment les présumées victimes il ya
des personnes qui le connaissent on a
été en contact avec les membres de sa
famille et au final on avait toutes les
versions de la faire sauf sa version à
lui donc on a décidé de lui écrire en
prison puisqu'il est incarcéré à la
prison de de bourg-en-bresse
actuellement on en voyait la lettre un
peu comme une bouteille à la mer et nous
a répondu deux mois plus tard une aide
de deux pages et il ya des passages qui
sont assez forts alors vous avez la
lettre de christian qui est celle là
c'est vrai que je vous ai répondu ça
vous a étonné bah oui c'est vrai on s'y
attendait pas parce que bon on sait que
c'est en prison que ça peut être filtré
quant à l'or on a vu un codétenu
christian quesada qui avait à témoigner
dans le documentaire c'est vrai que le
documentaire c'était assez compliqué
pour lui puisqu'il a tout les présumées
victimes qui témoigne que c'est un
document des actifs
forcément c'est un peu dur pour lui de
voir ça on sait qu'il a vu les
documentaires en prison et on lui a posé
des questions lui a demandé comment il
se sentait qu est ce qu ils avaient le
droit de faire ou ne pas faire
on apprend notamment par exemple qu'il
n'a pas le droit de faire un livre sur
la sphère pendant trois ans après sa
sortie de prison
c'est l' interdiction de le faire il
nous le dit dans le pré d'ailleurs ça
dans la lettre est-ce que vous pouvez
nous lire les passages très fort de
l'être c'est fou cette histoire gilles
verdez tout le monde c'est vrai que
voilà on a reçu une lettre des normes
aux quesada c'est énorme
ah oui c'est vrai que c'est ça c'est un
scoop franchement alors on s'y attendait
pas alors il commence en disant
pensez-vous réellement que je vais
consacrer du temps à quelqu'un
travaillant pour une chaîne donc ces
huit ou depuis 15 mois vous
eu de cesse de manier lynchage
médiatique insultes faux témoignage au
mépris de la plus élémentaire
présomption d'innocence donc là je
voudrais juste dire que dans le dollar
mais cela vous pouvez lui répondre que
c'est vous qui bien sûr évidemment dans
le documentaire on rappelle maintes et
maintes fois qu'il ya la présomption
d'innocence
en revanche nous on a enquêté on a été
sur le terrain on est allé rencontrer
les présumées victimes
évidemment on ne donne pas la parole à
n'importe qui avait certaines jeunes
femmes qui avaient des témoignages un
peu hasardeux on les a pas mis dans le
documentaire
quand vous rencontrez une jeune fille
que vous allez sur son téléphone que
vous voyez sur le son compte twitter que
c'est le compte de christian quesada qui
lui envoie des photos avec sa fameuse
histoire du zizi tordu voilà c'est un
peu compliqué donc la tendance à peser
tordu mais oui ils sont quesada presse
qu'il envoyait avait une excuse en fait
ils racontaient qui s'était tordu le
sexe etc qui était une histoire nous
inquiéter toujours la même mais qui est
un prétexte pour envoyer des photos de
son sexe à des jeunes femmes
voilà voilà bien un mot qu'elle débarque
sur la présomption d'innocence il ya
aucun problème de notre côté je vous
rappelle donc là il avoue je vous
rappelle que les faits pour lesquels
j'ai été interpellés sont certes graves
condamnable et donc condamnés mais cela
reste des délits qui par un aveuglement
se sont transformées en un procès
cathodique plus virulent que pour
fournir et le landais ou abdeslam heures
quand même pourquoi il se compare à
salade et sam c'est quand même n'importe
quoi parce que la faire elle a été
médiatisé sur ces 8 on en a parlé dans
la presse on en a parlé dans la presse
média s'est intéressé les français
puisque quesada c'est vrai qu'il fascine
les gens c'est l'histoire de ce sinistre
grave c'est véritablement servant du
rêve au cauchemar de ce type y était qui
a été sdf un moment de sa vie qui arrive
aux douze coups de minuit avec 2 euros
en poche chez lui entre il devait faire
un film sur question voilà sur sa vie
avant qu'on apprenne tout ça voilà mais
de là à se comparer à celle abdeslam ou
fournirait ça n'a rien à voir il ya une
médiatisation
certes c'est dur pour lui les faits
n'ont rien à voir les affaires n'ont
rien à voir ça n'a pas de sens il dit
qu'il est accusé d'un bail qu'il est
victime d'un lynchage médiatique
il vous adresse un petit mot cyril vous
remercierez votre patron pour cette
phrase collector à propos de michel
cymes vous avez dit ah ça apparemment je
suis contre l'acharnement médiatique
non mais lol quoi avec 3 ou alors voilà
ah oui contre lui puisque j'avais
défendu michel cymes elle lui dit qu'il
est victime d'acharnement médiatique
c'est pas le cas on a donné la parole à
des présidentes c'est vrai qu'on a fait
énormément de choses sur sur christian
quesada unis vrai que c'était une
affaire on parle de télé on parle de
médias c'est un homme bien sûr qui nous
concernait et qui concernait bien sûr
les téléspectateurs en plus nous
directement je vous l'avais dit tyreke
question quesada
on ne savait pas tout ça c'est vrai que
c'est quelqu'un qu'on a souvent en été
on avait même je vous le dis avec notre
boîte de production moment peut-être
un projet avec lui d'essayer de faire un
truc qui peut battre christian quesada
un peu dans le thème bah voilà sur des
questions et c'est vrai qu'on voulait
même de développer un jeu avec lui donc
forcément on a été tous choqués et
abasourdis quand on a appris voilà ce
qui s'était passé et de quoi il avait
été accusé
donc forcément voilà on n'a pas fait un
affichage médiatique mon à traiter la
faire et c'est vrai que c'est une
affaire qui rebondissait pratiquement
tous les jours oui j d'abord c'est un
document extraordinaire quoi parce que
quesada il n'avait jamais parlé
hélas qui dit bon il est à bourg en
bresse à l'isolément dans une cellule
tout seul donc je pense qu'il a eu ce
courrier il a eu envie de parler mais
moi je répondrai sur le fond ici quand
on a fait des débats plein de fois j'ai
essayé de contacter ses avocats il en a
changé aucune réponse avec benjamin
quand benjamin avait des documents ont
confronté toutes nos sources police
justice les témoins donc il ya eu aucun
acharnement il ya eu du journaliste d
enquête et je rappellerai quand même
qu'il a été condamné et il le reconnaît
dallaire 3 de reconnaître donc je pense
qu'il ne peut pas invoquer ça du tout
mais on sent quelqu'un qui visiblement
n'a pas digéré alors il dit quoi d'autre
dans la lèvre
il parle de benjamin qui avait fait
référence à nos qui dit comment peut-on
tolérer et donc cautionner que sur votre
plateau certains de vos collègues entre
guillemets demande la peine de mort
cannor est requis 20 ans de réclusion
sans qu'à aucun moment quelqu'un
interviennent pour ramener à la raison
c'est invraisemblable divagations donc
là il parle de ça
il parle après du réalisateur tient une
petite énigme à la fin on reconnaît son
ton parce que c'est vrai que sur son
twitter il parlait souvent comme un
jeune idole mdr et ses effets une énigme
à la fin il s'adresse à thibaut gitans
qui est l'autre réalisateur du
documentaire
dites à votre poggi ton de consulter la
page wikipedia du chanteur renaud mdr
d'accord pas compris mais il aime bien
faire des énigmes on sait qu'il est
comme ça il annule un jouet il aime bien
faire des petits messages codés donc
donc d'accord alors est ce que ses
avocats vous ont contacté on les a
contactés il a changé d'avocat comme
comme gilles à 10 c'est un dossier qui
est très compliqué à gérer puisque les
faits sont là il les reconnaît il dit
les faits sont certes graves condamnable
et donc condamnés il a changé d'avocat
il paraît les avocats nous ont dit quand
même qu'on avait également eu le
procureur il paraît que c'est une
affaire très compliquée à gérer que
quesada et très compliqué à gérer
ça fait combien quand il est incarcéré
là maintenant ça va faire celle-ci de
culasse 2019
donc ça fait plus d'un an il a été
condamné à trois ans de prison et si ça
se passe si se comporte bien il sera
libéré avant
est-ce que vous avez des infos oui il se
comprend très bien c'est à dire que
c'est un détenu considéré on y est pas
un pays comme modèle visiblement
effectivement il pourrait assez
rapidement six mois avant des niveaux
traditionnels il aurait quitté il avait
abandonné son avocat juste avant le
procès non c'est l'avocat qui a
démissionné jeter les ponts se mettre
camacho défense juste avant le procès je
veux simplement dire qu'il avait reconnu
les faits reprochés lors de sa garde à
vue il avait précisé n'être jamais passé
à l'acte et n'avoir jamais commis
d'agression est quand même important de
le rappeler et pardon mais ça
correspondait à une envie du public
parce que moi je me souvenais que le
premier des deux documentaires avait été
un record d'audience
donc ça nous ferons ne faisait que
correspondre et c'était étayée par l'anc
est un c'était c'était surtout l'enquète
voilà qui avait mené guillaume et oui
voilà qu'on a on avance j'ai envie de
savoir mais kelly non je sais que c'est
pas le sujet mais si on peut quand même
préciser l'injustice qu'il ya quand il
se passe des choses comme ça avec la
personne elle alors j'apprends qu'elle
sort dans six mois mais ça me dégoûte
alors quand on condamner une personne
n'a pas besoin de prison qu'elle fait
quand même eu la jambe il ya une
boutique traumatisé je vous rappelle
bien sûr oui dans le barème c'est la
reine ont couru à part faire la justice
on va juste sujet mais ça révoltant mais
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'en des condamnés
parce que là c'est pas la présomption
d'innocence et d antan les anciens
documentaire mais quand on a été
condamné pour des faits aussi graves
quand même que dit-il à ce qu'elle a
fait la moindre des choses tout cela va
faire un tout petit peu profil bas et
pas de ceux de ce surtout programme et
distributeurs de vendre moins eu de bons
et mauvais points médiatique mais c'est
tout c'est pas auto programme bien sûr
mais moi je vais vous dire ce qu'il a
fait machin je vomis la pédophilie je
vomis les viols je vomis tout ça et je
veux dire je l aime et de finir
pourparlers avec des enfants pas aux
efforts de jugement ce qui l'a énervé
c'est qu'un amalgame tout le monde a dit
oui ça pédophiles accord celui des
images de mineurs d endurance et des
viols de mineurs donc c'est très grave
ça ne fait pas de vous un pédophile il a
tapé les images il a été voir ces images
on rajoute vous mis ces mecs là voilà ça
c'est fait et je persiste et peut encore
envoyé notre lettre c'est moi qui le dit
on lui a répondu un pouvoir je persiste
et signe par contre je rentre je remet
juste un petit truc dans ce que tu as
dit quand il parle de diffamation pour
ton docte on dope ya pas de diffamation
sur ton docte on ne peut pas dire ici
nous pendant trois quatre cinq émissions
des semaines entières on l'a massacrée
en la d3 et c'est vrai un poney
commissariat on la remet son credo tombe
à la réunion il ya une émission on a dit
même peine de mort la raison machin j'en
attends florian dans des bars étaient
aussi on le vomi mais dans des bases
c'est possible et la réponse qui te fait
bah je vais te dire moi je t'aurais fait
peut-être la même réflexion
maintenant laissez le tranquille car
l'intérêt d'un référendum sur ce mec là
il le fera il le fera mais ne fera pas
que ces huit jeunes moins jeunes dit il
le dock qu'il le fera mais qu'une autre
chaîne nous avons déjà mais qui parle de
deux balles à djeddah après pour faire
vivre leurs rangs d'élus a rien dans sa
version pour avoir sa version des faits
bah oui pourquoi tu l'a appelé je n'ai
pas appelé pour avoir sa version des
faits à la soirée pour demander la bombe
pour faire un don qui va faire valider
la radio qu'il a déjà été fait m mais
c'est lui qui vont la faire
norman est en affaires